the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
obviously you're joining us in a very
amusing moment I was asking bacon please
don't miss any more checkmates at once
she said okay hello and I was asking you
to my legendary status apparently is
slipping Welcome to our show everyone
thank you for joining us we are here in
St Louis for the summer chess Classics
and we have been having a lot of fun
there you go yes hi and tell us after
after six rounds the tournament's uh
two-thirds over we are in round seven
first of all tell us the standings for
the group A standings group a Benjamin
bulk and nickel Theodore they're sharing
tying for First with four points and
Fanny flag that they are teammates
they're from uh Slough St Louis
University chess teammates at top
position shout out to slew right exactly
and for the for the third place we have
three ways tied to rollnak John and
pranav are tying for the second and
third with three and a half points and
it's going to be a huge fight between
those six players it's crowded at the
top and tell us about the standings for
Group B Asha Chandra is the solo leader
of the tournament this four and a half
points but he already made a draw today
so we'll see if samion Andrew or Armand
can catch up with him who are tying for
the second with four points outstanding
and as we go into the tournaments first
let's refresh our viewers memory about
the format for the two events it's two
10 player round robin tournament with 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and 30
minutes for the rest of the game is 30
seconds increment throughout the game
and the schedule I mean it's
straightforwards but nonetheless we're
close to end the tournament we have only
three rounds left and today is the round
seven and we have two more days and if
it's necessary we'll have playoffs as
well and a lovely necessary you're doing
great I love it very Charming as we get
a look at the playing haul and uh the
players are really intense sitting at
the board I don't know who that is but
the player who's cupping this Nicholas
yeah
this is Nichols Theodore there you go
and tell us about the pairings and what
our viewers can expect for this round
seven let's start with for group a we
have great pairings as always and our
key matcha for this round is John work
first versus pranav and they both have
two three and a half points and their
line scores are matching both players
have won two games lost a game let's
just jump into that game because for me
I thought uh coming out of this opening
this is a very theoretical stuff this
whole A4 A5 business it's been around
for a couple of decades and the
computers have really pushed the
boundaries of this particular opening I
mean there's a lot of funny moves Rook
B8 to avoid a b after the move Bishop E3
you wanted to be able to defend this
bishop there are lines where I take take
and suddenly the epon yeah so you go
Rook A8 Knight D2 h7h6 trust me there
are reasons for all of these moves
rookie eight Bishop B7 Knight F1 and we
got to exactly this point and now I was
confused used right here I thought
that
e 4 e 5 was the big move uh the whole
idea at least to my way of thinking was
I really want this uh Bishop opened up
and in the game and I thought you would
play Knight these Knight D5 yeah I kind
of imagine that this was uh the way and
I'm thinking to myself wow wouldn't it
just be great just to go all in on the
king side over there Queen C1 and then
the idea is to attack yeah and if you
take you know uh he didn't want to give
away his uh Bishop that was probably
Bishop on A8 and then B's A7 and B7 so
it starts to play for black exactly I
think that was the point of D5 yeah I
did it play the move D5 and I kind of
felt well
the board got hosed and again this isn't
one of those variations those openings
that are so sharp and so tactical and
the lines are so forcing that by the
time you get to the end of the variation
the game's a drawn because everything
got hosed off the board and as we catch
up with the players and we're not there
yet Queen C4 night before oh wait a
minute what a I don't know it's not an
easy position I was about to say
I thought we were gonna see King G7 or
something like that 1994
like solid player he loves to create
some mess on the board well he succeeded
with that last move because guess what
Bishop takes G6 and uh I would be scared
to be honest as black to play night
before because it's like
feels like it's too early you need to
develop your work first yeah there was a
movie with Bill Murray is called
volunteers and a troop Sergeant they
lost their sergeant and they were all
Misfits and Bill Murray was asked by the
general where's your sergeant blowed up
Sir well the king side just blowed up I
mean Bishop takes G6 well first of all
let whenever you're defending you've got
to exchange we trade off the attackers
I'm not saying that that's the only also
we can show why it's better to take a
note 3 for example if you take on G6
immediately yes which you did actually
commentators curse the moment you're
about to give it yes I was thinking if
you tried this just to protect Queen H6
Queen F7 then Knight G5 and queen G7 I
just take on G7 and Rook E7 and B7
Bishop is hanging is it is it hanging
that's the question well it is hanging
but there is I think PornHub that's why
he took well after night yeah night is
hanging too the night is hanging too
um wow uh but it could be then what
you're gonna do well he must be thinking
that the bishop is actually a better
piece than the Knight otherwise you take
it of course we're going to come back to
this game because this game is exciting
uh but tell us about the the pairings
for Group B as well
lovely group we already have
the tournaments right and elshon
unfortunately lost his game against
Brandon Jacobson it was a very that was
fast
fortunate games
um white pieces but our key matchup for
this round is batsuran versus Armand who
Arman has great chances to catch up with
akshat if he wins this round because
actually had made a draw and he has five
points and Armand has four points well
let's get to that game uh when now we
can see the players on our screen yeah
there we have it uh when we got to into
studio and again thank you so much for
joining us we got to this position and I
was explaining to you that America had
this turn of the century great Harry
Nelson Pillsbury and Pillsbury was an
extraordinary character
so for example he was very famous that
we'd have a dinner together
and you would bring a list of words 35
words and these words are the worst
words ever you know like some chemicals
some unbelievable words he'd look at the
words and during the dinner you have
your list and you would say
word number 34 and he would repeat it to
you word number 30 and he'd repeat it to
you word number ten and he repeated to
you exceptional he would do that while
playing with which is a a bridge game
and a simultaneous
chess simultaneously oh my God yeah I
mean it was off the charts like
remarkable he would play What became a
known uh as the Pillsbury attack he
loved to put his Knight on E5 in the
center of the board supported by the
pawn F4 and then the Rook left anyone
number when I was a kid it was my
favorite yeah I didn't get that right
or H3 you just made them exactly well uh
Herman said not so fast not so fast I've
got my tickles as well and he played in
this move in this position he moved B5
which uh to my eyes is very unusual a
move that I don't see often in these
positions normally speaking you know you
kind of expect that you know there was
going to be some
trades in the center or you know
countering B5 Queen B1 just kind of
getting off the C5 I keep putting the
pressure takes on D4 and right here that
was a surprise move for me uh I'm much
more familiar with the positions after
E3 takes D4 Bishop takes D4 takes takes
uh he's targeting B7 uh yeah he's that's
why he took on D4 so he can open up the
queen that is true that was uh that was
his intention in in terms of the
recapture B5 B4 and now black may very
well be threatening to take take and
play Knight G4 upon on E5 is a potential
weakness he traded traded I always like
throwing in those checks uh driving my
opponents it's kind of annoying too it
feels like he doesn't make a move yeah
yeah yeah and uh the nice part is when
the bishop is on such a diagonal this is
coming with the tempo uh Queen B2 F6
Bishop B1 Bishop C5 we've caught up with
the players and uh well just I likewise
position I like White's perspective of
attack but in long term I like Black's
position if he cannot attack me then
most probably You're Gonna Lose Your C4
Pawn
and there you go so uh the the situation
really kind of calls for white to step
up the attack or to King to continue his
attack I don't know if Queen C2 is The
Right Move uh to do that to try to
provoke something the players are
fighting hard begum absolutely oh what
are they fighting for let's start with
the price fund for the a group price for
a fund for the a group is first place
six thousand dollars second place four
thousand dollars third place three
thousand dollars and then rest of the
tournament also they are gonna get great
prizes and the total prize fund of the
tournament is twenty two thousand
dollars very nice and uh in group b what
are those players number three is
fighting for first place four thousand
dollars second place two and a half
thousand dollars and third place two
thousand dollars and the rest of this
players also get some good prizes with
the total price fund of 14 000 thank you
St Louis thank you St Louis chess club
and Scholastic Center we did say as we
were coming on the air that we do have
some results and let's just take a look
at those results I don't think anything
really happened in the game between Luca
and akshat because essentially the
players played it very very solid solid
line I have a feeling both players today
decided I'm gonna be so I'm not gonna
risk anything it sure seemed like they
really knew what they were doing too as
the players went through a very very
topical line and I remember seeing this
position for the first time it was a
game of Vichy Anand advice
and I thought that was hilarious yes
I just thought this was very funny two
pieces are hanging I'm looking and
analyzing Bishop a510 maybe even Knight
D5 is an option right you're creating so
many like weak points in the position
exactly and then why you don't want this
I then and then this move Bishop A3 I
thought it was hilarious guess what it's
become the main topical move in the
position engine approved in all that rut
once again we have a very solid position
for both players nobody risked anything
I do believe it was a preparation until
Rooks to sell milk A7 by both players
and there you have it and a draw was
soon agreed
but we had an accident
or rather al-shawn had a serious
accident in his game with Brandon now
this is all just very common stuff um
um
would it be called a zuccher tort I'm
not even sure what they call this uh
opening but if he had played E2 E4 it
would have been a perk defense with a
symmetrical fianchetto
um Alshon went for a little bit of space
on the queen side and for me I should
say A3 is an interesting
uh where are you going this is a very
confusing move D6 D5 maybe it's Theory
all I'm saying is maybe it was his
preparation again these days you will
never know right yeah it never works
um
how can I put this uh well uh Bishops
obviously Rooks need open file stuff
yeah Bishops need open diagonals but V2
is a bigger diagonal than A3 to begin
with but this diagonal is actually
closed because of the D6 so if you were
for example just I'm just throwing some
moves on the board uh go chop chop chop
chop chop the bishop is closed and the
bishop is going to come back on B2
so what do you do you open the dial for
your opponent's Vision so
I'm like okay that move for me
totally totally
tasered confused you you tell me I don't
even know how to describe it I think you
need to invite
to explain it to explain for us what are
you doing uh 95 I find that as a strange
move I have a feeling it's an attempt to
attack D5 and try to justify Bishop A3
because if you take on E5 then yeah my
Bishop is playing Attack on 97. so for
me I you know everybody's developed
everybody's good everybody's good except
for one guy good good good this is what
I do I do I I uh how about you well not
so good you could get me into the game
coach and how about you oh coach you
really need to get me into the game so I
would find the move Queen D3 like
instantly attractive the idea is just to
bring the Rooks into the center and yes
of course I do want to play for E2 E4 95
okay
F4 Pillsbury attack anybody okay but
haven't I weakened E3 yeah well okay I
can cover okay so no harm no foul go
ahead Play Bishop F5 prompt me to
sacrifice in exchange
I'll do it F7 F6 okay I chase the Knight
so let's chase it some more of course
I'm going to play H3
I'm going to drive the Knight back and
now I'm going to sit and think and now I
wish the picture was on Beat it
yeah you see it
right okay I'm gonna go okay so what am
I worried about I'm worried that the
night's gonna come to F5 and where the
bishop is going to come to F5 of course
I'm going to play the move E4 and so
what do you think you're going to do
probably I should take or which one play
F the E6 right
sorry you're going to do what is black I
just played E4 yeah I'm thinking should
I take an E4 or play E6 because if I
take an E5 you take on D5 I take on D4
and then most probably you'll just
retreat with the Knight right okay so
I'm not sure about that position maybe
it's good maybe
okay sorry uh give me a move
I want the audience to know what you're
talking about E5 F takes E5 D take C5
you just take that I was thinking of
e-text D5 and it takes D4 that position
okay and then who who do you want to
play white or black
I got a calculator well no I mean you
you if you just take it like that
probably E6 and
um
okay okay
and this position now you Justified your
Bishop on a little bit right a little
bit a little bit you cannot still play
Bishop D6 because Knight F7 is coming I
was thinking about the exchange
sacrifice and what that might mean uh
for the position uh
I thought
elshon
intention was to go H3 Drive the night
back play E4 he blundered he took took
and played E4 and this is
instantly yeah instantly uh whatever you
call it and you had a you had a
conversation uh with Brandon yeah as we
came on the air you were telling me go
ahead tell the audience what happened
what was going on with the players at
this moment so uh basically he said that
elsham was confident about his position
played played like completely said 496
uh what he missed in Brandon's opinion
is like rookie six and then he totally
missed that after Queen D4 Knight text
C8 which was played in the game and
queen takes E4 suddenly he is check
after that's that's what happened right
I think maybe his preparation or idea
was not to take on F6 but immediately
play E4 and he totally forgot about it
and he was confident about still his
position you think he just mixed up his
yeah it's just like not proper maybe
it's not a preparation maybe it's just
like move or further sometimes you just
make moves you're by hand yeah you know
without literally thinking about it
exactly maybe that's what happened with
elshon as well it was a disaster
whatever happened
in 18 moves and I like to say this to
the audience I'll share it again where I
say it all the time I don't mind losing
yeah that's okay that comes with the job
you're going to play chess you're going
to lose a lot of games prep yourself
learn from them the games I hate to lose
is where I don't learn anything you
didn't teach me anything I just made
this horrible blunder and that's where
elshon is right now he doesn't he's just
angry with himself yeah because he
didn't learn anything from this game he
just blundered it right away yeah and I
hate that it caused a lot of frustration
oh and coming back painful it is painful
painful so two results in that group one
result in the other group let's go to
that I thought this was our leader of
the tournament
Benjamin book made a draw I think after
yesterday's disaster he didn't want to
play today he's like no matter what it
will end in a draw anyways right well
Benjamin's having this roller coaster
ride of a tournament so I think he
wanted to solidify a little bit he's
like okay and for me this as we were
coming on air that was probably why you
saw us giggling I'm laughing at the move
Bishop B5 and I'm telling you it's just
modern world not only did you tell me it
was Modern movies showed me
Fabi carijuana Magnus Carlson uh Ali
reason who else has played this movie
but Wesley so I mean let's go I mean the
line of 2 800 players who have played
this move is deep and I'm going garbage
it's just garbage ridiculously if you
had shown this move to a player from the
18th century they would kick me out
they were playing chess right you know
you you got to learn about development
opening principles don't move the same
piece twice blah blah blah blah and you
go no no no
understand I'm from the 21st century I'm
from 200 years in the future I'm here to
teach you guys
they would be like what okay put this
guy in the mental levels Bishop A4 okay
castles castles looks to me like it's a
loss of a Tempo and uh funnily enough if
you look at this position you'd say whoa
why isn't black happy he has save King
good development his fair share of the
center I don't I mean if I could get
this every game with black
I signed me up I I have no issues and in
fact uh after some trades in the center
we had get this more trades in the
center
and the players achieved a completely
even position
and this is a funny part of it exactly
now that we've achieved this position
how are we going to make a draw let's
repeat it let's repeat the position okay
there we have it a draw and let's get to
our Marquee match up again John John uh
where are you yes third one okay this is
where we have just left it and
we kind of thought oh dear they hacked
their way to an even position nothing's
going on
and then this matchup is that both
players love to play messy positions
crazy ideas they they got it Bishop
takes G6 just blowed up the board takes
rookie seven oh that's a very smart move
so I don't have Queen F7 Queen G7 no
Bishop takes F3 as you just pointed out
Queen takes H6 you don't have uh Queen
F7 as a defense anymore you're busted
rookie seven
Rook C8 okay returning the piece uh he's
going to get one of his pawns back
wow and then A5 one is a witness two
King h
uh
um I'm threatening Queen H6
okay and try to keep the king H2 Bishop
D5 Queen takes HH that is a very weird
defense I would say Knight E5 Queen C1
I'm still having a very very hard time
uh following the play white white should
be winning here I would say even after
Queen H4 what's your idea
no no I think this is completely
terrible that I have to ask the question
I'm a piece down why don't I win the
piece back
I mean if I win the piece back
two pawns on and his hopes to just to
grab A5 Pawn on or B2 pawn and try to do
something like so for example first of
all I'm winning the piece back with the
check that's a pretty bad sign right
yeah absolutely no yes sir I'm not
saying black is doing no no of course
not so was it just a blunder day seven
probably enough total blunder uh so once
again we're back here and I was confu we
were confused pardon me I apologize
uh whenever you're defending the rule of
thumb is trade off the attacking pieces
I don't want to see the Knight jumping
the E5 I don't want to see the Knight
jumping the G5 I don't want to see the
night jumping it was the same problem I
take on H6 you take on G6 I I play
rookie seven is it the same problem as
before no problem so Bishop G6 was a
Miss already ah so now Queen H7 Queen h8
is the threat now you take an group
meet on the seventh right so he played
F4 yeah not Queen H4 F4 and then he's
most probably crushing oh I'm sure he is
crushing Brooke
went to scene two
I guess F4
dreaming of her Perpetual check
wow okay what's the most crushing what
what would you advise what is your
advice
advice to the players I wonder if I can
simply take or not or can you do the
Perpetual check
if you can do then I I most probably I
just need to play Queen G5 it's a weird
move but it must be winning because
you're going to find idea very simply to
protect you to make sure there's no
perpetual and then you just check on F7
that was my question if I can take on F7
right exactly yeah so the idea was Rook
G2 most probably I will just escape the
[Music]
is an idea always and then I should be
fine exactly and then even if you take
on F7 the problem is that you give away
those change yeah
um
so he just pardon me I'm going to
refresh the board as John Burke looks
like he's cashing it you know it's a
funny thing but
I I kind of like your queen G5 as well
just from the perspective of like not
even I I just don't even know what black
is going to do as a defense I would have
played Knight takes F7 myself as I said
but F4 Rook G2 Knight takes F7 is on the
board and I'm anticipating
was that the moment and think about the
position
just look at the position
I'm threatening me Queen h8 made right
I'm threatening who he takes I mean you
have no choice now is not the time to
think you play Rook G2 and and let the
guy show you why he doesn't I mean you
need to stop to regret about your
decisions yes I got plenty of time to
read regret if you don't do it after the
game you
try to understand what what went wrong
and I feel like it's kind of we try to
torture our opponents uh as well as to
just as well as theirs yes right it's
just like they need to witness all of
this process you know what I mean to be
there yeah by the way I'm just looking
at the position
can we decide
way absolutely we can too I mean it's an
option you know you kind of there's no
check even more tricky about it Queen B2
Queen C3 if you go to HR work on F6 but
after Queen G5 still I have three two
queen G3 Queen C3 Queen F6 then Queen G5
and no more checks at all uh yeah that's
I'm just yeah King to H4 this looks over
over let's uh let's check in on Ilya
Ilya has drawn all of his games
yesterday it was not safe for him yeah
absolutely yeah that was not pretty and
they shook hands John Burke just won his
game yeah
and that was uh that was a very cute
tactic he wrote Bishop G6 rookie Bishop
G6 won it won the game for John uh
jumping into the game of Alias for a
moment uh
well uh do we call this the five puns
attack
one
I think they oh when you're playing
when you're playing a king's Indian and
you play F4 E4 D4 C4 yeah that's the
four pawns attack and I've Got Five
Pawns on the fourth ring and the A5 Pawn
as well so maybe you're right maybe we
have to call it the six Bond attack
don't discriminate count all of them yes
okay uh
well guess what we've just made it a a
conclusion that white has a lot of space
yeah that what's he doing with the space
is he is he translating it to an
initiative you remember we talked about
pronounce game when his opponent moved
to H4 G4 everything right forward and
then it has a huge problem
immediately those pawns became
weaknesses so you're saying there's a
possibility of white doesn't mind his
blow whatever it is the Black Knights
you should be careful they jump they do
but in this position white has pretty
good control the Knight of C5 is
embedded that's why you have space and
most probably a little bit more pleasant
position but the problem is that for
example if I play Knight A3 Knight AC4
after that
uh let's see who's on turn by the way
it's white on turn the last move was
King h8 is he trying to attack himself
to put F5 I think he's preparing a fight
some quiet move so just uh out of
curiosity if I go H5 now I can take on
H5 and play Rook G8 I'm faster okay okay
then F6 I get you I get you uh the one
thing about the Rooks is they're kind of
more or less ready flexible yeah they're
ready to come over you could take and
take I mean queen of six
it's okay I like it probably probably
I put your queen on the wrong Square I
apologize for that but uh something you
you said he made a quiet move what move
did he make we'll find out he played
King h8
it's a current smoke right now King on
GT he played King G2 okay cool we don't
have the move yet but he played King G2
okay I like that move you were about to
wait a sec so King h8 wasn't wasn't the
correct move he played H5 it seems like
H5 G5 King F7 King G2 it seems like we
have totally different position you lose
me what what did he do I mean or maybe
our
transmission is behind in general
because I do see a black Pawn on each
five right the iPhone on H5 and white
Pawn on G5 King on F7 and King on G2
Queen on E2 so we have a little bit
different positions than on broadcast
yeah I suspect after King AJ we have
King G2 I'll just uh make a guess
that
oh they're repeating the most H5 you can
put the pawn on H5 Queen on
you're right they are repeating and I
was about to say I mean uh yeah we're
not getting the moves coming in but uh
they are going back and forth yeah
really amazing straw he is seven in a
row I mean I don't know what that is
insane he's repeating yeah officially
they made a draw
and hopefully we'll get the transmission
back and we can check try to understand
so shukran is claiming draw
well uh for me I'm a bit surprised
because I like eliu's position the six
pawn attack
with control over the C5 Outpost
I would think that white is for choice
and again we don't know how the position
it seems that position became completely
blockaded yeah yeah you cannot make a
move I cannot make a move right and I
was thinking that White's idea might be
to play H5 they are checking to make
sure that it was a correct repetition
um my client here we go congratulations
pardon me my camera
the the Arbiter there put the kings in
the center congratulations
I predicted that Aram is gonna
have nine draws as well and he wasn't
thrilled about my prediction he's my
friend and now but ILY is following his
footstepsi
uh coming to the game of RM and darush
I don't like white
I don't like it too because here it's
one of those situations where black has
the imbalance of a rook against two
minor pieces
are the best course minor pieces yeah
and the two pawns So materially speaking
darush stands better but secondly also
his P his Rooks this look is tremendous
this Rook is tremendous these Knights
don't have what we would call stable
outposts outposts so if you put the
Knight on G6 you would say okay it's
supported by the pawn and it's stable I
mean at least if you had Knight on F4
and Knight on E2 that would be a
different position but Knight on D4 is
vulnerable like I can play C5 yeah and
kick it out exactly and then I don't
like this even though I don't like what
darush did in the opening I thought what
Doris did in the opening which is
terrible they got this crazy sky
yeah and you know
it's just like uh uh if I was a coach
and I saw a black queen on Essex
uh in front of the bishop on C8
I would say to the student we need to
train
we need to we need a lot of work
actually
besides moved to me like Queen E6 not
Queen G6 yeah yeah the crazy part is
life is threatening this is theory and I
hate it for black I just think that this
is a really just a bad bad situation I
don't love this line for black is to
just develop Bishop on D7 and you got to
play F5 it's all like as long as you
push F5 usually you're fine with black
yeah is that the way it goes uh I just
don't like this position at all for
black I think it's I also don't like it
I play it with white yeah you like
everything from what I think that this
position but unfortunately you don't
have much uh I don't understand the move
Queen D2 for for me I find this move uh
perplexing uh it's clear you want to get
the bishop out right and I appreciate
that so you get the queen out of the way
but to my way of thinking you know you
put your queen on E6
you know anytime I can develop with the
tempo uh I'm interested just like I'm
interested I'd like to I like to kick
your queen I'm supposing black wants to
play like in the game because do you
want to play F5 is it okay
okay and so we get a position more or
less
uh similar to the game and I'm thinking
I'm here first uh what do I do with it
exactly
how do I exploit uh that that beautiful
moment hmm how do I exploit this moment
trick me here I am trying to trick you
here
um maybe Rook h e eight yes and just
staying staying at their
it is weird to me I am not making any
inroads on your position
are you attacking I am how about
tricking you can I take on e4 Rook D6
Bishop H3 do you have
do you have anything no no
no I I
how do you say I don't
then I can take on H3 I know you take on
D6 I take text you don't have anything I
don't have anything
the answer is trying I'm trying to trick
you can I take on H3 how many what's the
body count
I don't know what the body count is at
the moment it's like Bishop nine two
minor pieces for uh look yeah and then
you're taking your phone back uh let's
see what happened because I'm not a fan
of what white or black setup and I'm not
a fan of the move Queen D2 let's just
see how it went the players reached
probably for all I know a theoretically
approved position it feels like they
knew what they were doing
yeah well that's a very responsible move
I think that's a very bold move that's
me too
wow okay well the problem is the night's
trapped yeah I had no choice I actually
huh is that true
you are choosing to nice
look great okay it's the night night
before
yes thank you
oops you blundered you blundered you
blundered it so I need to play Rook do
you want Rook G1 okay yes there's like
no you blunder no means
Knight D4
and probably this is the problem right
yeah the Knight is actually just trapped
uh I could give up the exchange but that
was definitely not the idea when I did
this so he took on F3 and now it's one
of those things I think it's all about
it
exactly judgment call right so when
white played G4 he judged that this
position was going to be good for him
when white plate G4 and darush captured
on F3 gadaru made the Judgment this
position is good for him in my opinion
black is doing very well I'm more than
curious uh
how the players are going to come in and
evaluate and share their their Viewpoint
uh for me I like black I don't know I
love this Rook
and like you said the the Knight on D4
the fact that it's vulnerable to C5
makes me think after I'm on time
and then I will go back with the night
maybe I'm holding it true uh gosh
[Music]
wow by the way we just got word that
Andrew hung
Ry is in town
he has won and he won fast against uh
Alexander lunderman yeah
looks a little bit suspicious yeah as we
came on air as you mentioned uh Bishop
E5 let's go back to this yeah more or
less the players reach this position
very quickly well we're gonna get Andrew
so if somebody's gonna rotate out
okay we're gonna lose you yet again yes
all right I will I will have it and uh
when we left uh well as we were coming
in on air we didn't like
uh Linderman's position
right here we felt that white was the
one for choice and to explain all the
action and Andrew is going to join us
and uh
tell us what happened welcome to the
show Andrew yeah I mean it's going well
at least we have nice interviews
together yeah uh what well first of all
uh what do they call this opening Dragon
dwarf this is the dragon door I mean he
played the classical song with G6 which
is I'd say quite rare and um
I remember this idea with uh yeah 9294
is quite good for white or it's quite
good and it's not um it's not the most
common way to play so I thought
might as well give it a try okay
and um well it sure looked like you knew
what you were doing I mean because uh
for for ourselves
when we like I said when we came to town
uh exactly In This Moment
uh we we liked your position how did how
did you feel yeah well I knew like
usually when um you take on E6 and then
even though it looks strange to put the
bishop on C4 because he got hit with
tempo right as long as you like keep
this bishop here and the pressure on the
E6 Pawn is um and I knew this type
position it's better for one it's um
it's supposed to be at least um okay it
looks quite unpleasant for black uh I
kind of like the move Bishop F4 but
should he have played Bishop E5 here did
you did what was your should he play
Bishop what was your thoughts
um Bishop B5 I mean it was a possible
move but I think the the issue when he
was um struggling yeah what he was
struggling with was uh yeah this bishop
um it can eventually be easily kicked
with F4 right and this this pressure is
still um extremely unpleasant and fair
fair I mean you're right F4 is going he
played 95. yeah actually
for instance if um I think the media F4
was was made one of his concerns
because if you take one out for them you
take on that five exactly this comes
Under Fire so right that's why he chose
95 okay and Bishop B3
um yeah I'm never afraid of knights
before because I can just take on that
five everything collapses feels bad yeah
okay so he found an interesting idea
Rook F6 pretty sure his idea was if 92
which looks very natural
um hitting Bishop maybe not going to D4
so I think this should be better for
what I mean because if you trade the
Queens both pawns will drop right but um
Queen H4
rookie two this looks fine for white I
think
um say it's 94 just H3 double edge so
hold on just a second just a second and
if I go Rook Cafe yeah I mean you can
play Rook Cafe but here at least I can
take the temple ah sorry and then all
right D6 actually no I think we're
really six oh Rook D6 is much more
convincing yeah Knight G4 H3 and then
the point is I think if you taken off
two there's nothing here Black's King is
weaker
um and if you take with the Rook um at
least like let's say Rook D1 or
something
um that's what I was thinking and this
looks and I'll push back your pieces and
then I think and then yeah
that will collapse but after 92 I
thought his idea was this interesting
with G5 okay so it's extremely strange
but Rook H6 is coming and I think if
you're forced to take enough for this
might not be the greatest
um position for white because Black's
solve most of his problems
um yeah if it takes probably what it
takes okay
um and then like Quincy there's a
natural movement volume Rook H6 right
and G3 is coming next but now it'll take
on e4 and um well it black is looking
for yeah any any anything that kind of
confuses matters because but so that's
why I played Knight B5 which I think is
stronger okay I'm hitting D6 and I'm
uncommon to D4 okay and queen might come
to C3 and it might be Knight C7 as well
on a good day as well yeah and the the
key point is that I don't block my Rook
so if he takes I can always just take
and then let's say D5 to come back his
this these weaknesses aren't going
anywhere so it's like the structure
just kind of collapses yeah it's really
tough for him to defend here I think
okay knife time was a decent try and
here I think it was important to find
just taking Queen H4 idea
um because what looks natural is 94 but
I'm not sure that white crashes through
after Bishop E5 because yeah because
this was his whole concept when he went
Bishop H6 to F4 was to get a secure
right Bishop on E5 yeah say you can like
track some variations here let's see if
like Bishop takes these that was the
first variation that begum wanted to
play yeah because okay if 96
unfortunately there does not seem to be
a win here and then queen of sticks next
right holding on the bishop takes looks
very interesting there's Bishop takes D4
um and that I the best I saw was this
but I mean life's better but I don't I I
thought I should have something better
than this exactly and also is Knight G5
ever an issue for you oh if Knight G5 I
thought Queen H4 simple chess and then
yeah I've taken this drops of 19
this was like not so clear to me because
right we got this position because
there's a rook H6 business right yeah
and then if you play F4 then at least I
thought black can take here and then now
this track right and then Queen F6 and
again okay it's holding on now yeah he's
struggling yeah so I didn't see anything
better but I was very happy to find
Queen Detroit which I think probably
just kills black
um the point is that Bishop E5 now F4
strong I think I agree that's a take
okay not Rook B1 because I think A6
something is okay okay but uh just
simply Bishop takes E6 so the point is
this pinned strong exactly and look I
have so many discoveries and I can also
take and take on these things so it
looks like his position is collapsing
agreed again yeah so that's why he
played Bishop G5
and queen G3 I thought was the simplest
um Queen before I mean he can still hold
on with rookie and it looks terrible too
but
yeah yeah I saw something with Queen B4
F4 and night yeah D4 yeah I saw I saw
this for instance I mean maybe you can
try this but I didn't see it before even
this yeah this obviously should be bad
for black but it's not the cleanest way
I thought okay like Still Holding On And
if you play Queen deforge threatens this
um okay E5 and F4 probably was very
strong pretty but uh I thought he has a
defense king of f8 here which is still
holding on somehow because if it takes
the fruit d8 if F4 just Bishop races
it's one of those things he's just home
but it's all tactical but I didn't see
the clearest way but I thought Queen G3
because this hits this Pawn
um it's a pin he's running f4h4
for instance like if Rook 36 I mean I
can take here and then like I'd rarely
staff this one and everything is
dropping agreed so if he I guess he has
to try out four and here I have like two
very good options Queen G4 Queen C3 I
thought both were strong Queen C3 again
hitting each six
um he can not play E5 because I take and
D6 Falls right so right
um one of the fences I thought he could
try is King machine
um
and then here's ideas 967
Rook C8
but it's important to continue the line
nice time king of Fate yeah you take
then take it's not so easy but I think
95 should win here
that's very beautiful yeah that's very
very to destroy black structure we
frequency you know that kills all the uh
Harmony and in the position here I think
take us to the easiest and okay
everything's starting so this should win
as well
um but I thought Queen G4 is completely
winning as well because of the H5 which
is very natural than rookie six and once
I win this Pawn this Bishop's opened up
this Pawn drops everything drops so
beautiful
um E5 drops yeah Bishop takes off sound
so
um I don't know what to try from like
you played rookie ain't yeah but 94 is
good but this is probably simplest okay
it takes takes you can't go here before
it takes D6 oh so
yeah here Rook D4 and this this probably
wins by force hitting this Pawn yeah you
can't ever go here because the trade
right this drops Knight is hanging yeah
so you try this but like this last week
when Bishop E6
here everything falls
um it's not only that you played a very
good game but it just feels like you
calculated it very well sometimes you
know you win a nice game yeah but you're
you you feel like well maybe I was this
was a very good game you feel you
feeling good about your tournament and
this one in particular well the torment
they're still like a long way to go but
um right at least this game was decent
so more than decent Andrew
congratulations I I I
when you're preparing your best games I
just gotta put this one aside it might
it might make it yeah thank you thank
you so much cheers
and we have a number of results and uh
one very very important result too was
from John Burke and he won a very nice
game
uh with this beautiful sacrifice on G6
which actually I want to say it was a
stunning sacrifice we certainly hadn't
seen it John nice to see you nice to
meet you welcome welcome tell us about
today's game
um I will first of all say that I missed
a million things
a million not just yeah there's one or
two this one and also if you like a key
uh tell us when your prep kind of
stopped and you just
so far it's all standard yeah so right
here is the first critical moment so
from my understanding Bishop B7 is
inaccurate the main line is rookie eight
exactly and then white can play a number
of things white can for example play
this line and sacrifice the pawn anyway
or it takes E4 Knight G3 and it's very
complicated exactly but the problem with
the move order that he chose is that it
lets me get my knight around without any
problems then the moment the Knight gets
to G3 life is very very good for you and
this always will win a piece indeed
so I knew that white is clearly better
here right and
yeah I didn't know how much better but I
knew that this would be nice for me
this was exactly my thought right here
stop for just just a second because I
already felt your position overwhelming
is strong but really good
yeah very very promising uh you had that
feeling at the board as well you played
so here it's like you have a number of
things you can do you can go I don't
care Queen D3 Rook D1 you can go D5 you
can go E5 you know like you've got these
promising choices options you came up
with the move D5 which I think is a very
good move how did you reject the others
other because here it's good right I
have a lot of choices right yeah you
know it's tough when you have a lot of
good options right right so like I have
to be careful like Queen D3 C5 if I let
him get C5 C4 clear um so you might go
for example Queen C2 then in that case
right just to avoid C5 C4 but I think C5
is too slow
yeah maybe but black the thing is the
reason I chose D5 is because it's um
positionally good for me if this stuff
with Queen C2 C5 if it doesn't work out
tactically for me then he can get
counter play but after D5 even if I
missed something it's not as concrete so
I'll just be better strategically
exactly and how did you reject E5 E5
well because that's also very forcing
right you look at the forcing moves
first right yeah I know there are
similar lines where black plays while
the Knight is still on C6 e takes d4c
takes Knight B4 and then white plays E5
Knight D5 and so here is a version where
the Knight is on E7 instead of B4 which
I think should favor Black and I didn't
see anything concrete here so I I to
keep it stable it's funny because you
just look at this position and I was so
in love with your position already at
this point you know I I even like
consider you you know like these kinds
of things already I just it's like one
of those positions that
You're Gonna Go rookie for yeah
you're telegraphing your your punches
and and I it just felt like he had
blundered to allow you these
possibilities and I thought at the at
this point Queen C2 E5 D5 you've got
these wonderful options you played D5
and you did it because you knew that
even if tactically things don't work out
for you you're not taking any risk and
you're pressing exactly okay very good
so at this point
how how much of an edge did you think
you had did you think it was so I kind
of I didn't have to play Ricky I could
play more slowly Queen D2 than I thought
he would play 95. maybe even that was
objectively correct because I just kind
of did this on Instinct I thought my
position is just so nice but the thing
is if he has time to play Rook d8 for
example then he can come close to
equality exactly so here uh probably I
didn't play it the best way I didn't
really know what else to do like the
point is he wants to play Rick D if I
play Rook C1 the idea of Rook d8 Rooks
c66 but she simply takes the pawn and I
didn't really see any follow-up here
which is a little bit surprising well
he's hitting my Bishop so I don't really
have time to do a whole lot here right
and
how annoying very annoying there were I
can play other moves Queen D2 crossed my
mind and then protecting A5 maybe just
well playing slowly yeah prepping uh the
triple I thought Rick Ricky too maybe
it's coming after these pawns and
again it gets weird yeah it was hard to
work it out but I thought the shipsy too
I thought it was nice okay but maybe
because things uh blowed up yeah
[Music]
about all of that is forced I can play
Bishop B3 here as well but right I went
for rookie one
and here's an important moment where if
you can have six that was my question so
I was thinking Queen dessert and then
Knight takes A5 and first of all I can't
win a piece with like B4 because Bishop
takes F3 clear so I was thinking 95 and
right next I'm threatening Queen's seven
before it looks very good right
um and he can never play Queen T5
because the F7 Pawn is hanging but after
Rook fade I was kind of seeing this from
afar and I didn't see a win yeah if it
does exist if it does exist Queen C7
looks good at first but then I gave up
the E8 square and he plays rookie eight
which begs the question John yes uh Rook
d8 well here I think Queen C7 and rookie
true maybe Knight C4 maybe Knight G4 was
the thing here ah okay although okay it
still that is why you wanted Rook f8
yeah not Rook d8 okay it's not over here
maybe
this is I think King G7 United 16 t7
yeah then I might lose
okay but it was it was hard to to see if
there was a win there
um because we we we're gonna get to this
very you saw Bishop G6 from afar yeah I
mean when I played rookie one Queen C4
Queen D2 I saw it and uh
I thought it was very likely to occur
because after Queen D2 he doesn't really
have many other options he if he defends
upon with King G7 then at the very least
I can drive from back with rookie for
Queen C5 B4 or something like that just
and then start looking uh
Westward yeah because my only problem is
my A5 Pawn is hanging sometimes so if I
have that under control it'll just be
good
uh Bishop takes G6 you got here yeah
yeah so here actually I missed something
quite large so in from afar I was
looking at this line and I thought this
was funny at 95. Rook takes Queen C6 out
of nowhere I'm just kind of trash I can
still play Rook B6 and play that and I'm
probably wow yeah probably still better
there but okay
um so my intent was to play 95 but I
just completely missed Queen E4
now I'm worse I think
why why Queen H6 97 I'm sorry your Rook
is hanging apologies so here like 97 for
example right and I'm in trouble maybe
or at least well it's uh yeah yeah
it's a fight and I I only realized that
afterwards so here I would have had to
go for this Rook p7 Queen to six Rook be
six line and just play that because oh
my yeah I just didn't see Queen E4 I
thought it's one of those Illusions when
you're calculating that you forget the
Rook was guarding the E4 square but you
put your knight in front so now the
queen has access I was thinking Queen C8
96 and completely winning gotcha but
yeah he he didn't see the idea of 95 I
guess oh my
so mutual Mutual blindness it's so
common in chess yeah I mean absolutely
rookie seven Queen D2 and then it was
kind of funny here exactly at this
moment what kind of funny is it wrong uh
uh word you could play Knight takes F7
and of course he was going to play Rook
Jake's G2 and he was like thinking
thinking yeah you're like there's no
other move that right next to you too
and then yeah I assume in a king H4 yeah
making just trying to set the boards
yeah I mean there's a million ways which
is one example line is right
uh like kinshi for Quincy and King H4
exactly we've seen there are many ways
John very important victory for you
congratulations thank you uh looking
looking forward to the championship
rounds I suppose how do you play
tomorrow I play Benjamin Benjamin yes
big match good luck thank you thank you
John for joining us and uh we will uh
take a look at the other games that are
still remaining uh begin will join us
Megan wanted to put one of the uh arum's
Knights to F4 she will be very pleased
to learn that Aaron took her advice and
did that but I still
have friends for life I even though he's
done what you suggested begum I still
don't like White's position I think it's
uh it's all
all black here I would say I just like
the setup yeah just look at
um the knights
uh it's always been my perspective the
knights
have a very strange property and it's a
property that you should really keep in
mind when you play over The Grand Master
games you see where they put the knights
but Knights
improve
when they're protected it's a very
strange property
this night is better on D5 than where it
currently is because it's protected by a
pawn and knights are constantly
searching for outposts and when they are
we we even we even say the knights in
the air the night's just kind of like uh
drifting around when the nights are
unprotected they often find themselves
under trouble looking at this position I
feel that darush he'll play a moves like
H5 King C6 B5
but the good thing is about the
disposition as long as I control H Pawn
most probably I will make a draw first
of all and secondly not if you move the
king my Knight's gonna jump as well uh
sorry if I move the king so I I did I I
intended I'm like no immediately I
cannot do that maybe night King E3 and
Rook H3 and Knight D5 slowly I can
improve as long as I have some squares
for for my nights I'm not like hopeless
yeah that's a that's a good point uh
King E3
my idea is like for example if you play
B5 right okay yeah I know there are many
complications in this position because I
just want to make a point sure okay
night EC3
exchanged yeah to C3 yeah we exchange on
C4 for example sure and then my idea is
just to put my E2 Knight on D5 not F4 so
I can control your H Pawn
so these two nights one night will be
sitting pretty on D5 the other night
will be sitting on F
4 and you are you sure you're
controlling this Pawn but yeah okay you
you you get the setup yeah you get the
setup you want and uh the thing is that
I'm not only controlling I have to yeah
but we're talking in general but yeah
right but it's okay we'll we'll get a
check yeah
[Music]
and we'll put them on so yeah I just
stay maybe A4 yes so A4 and so your your
thought at least is that the knights
controlling each word but like I'm kind
of controlling your G4 Rook G4 as well
so and then my weakness on C4 has not uh
like not as much reasonable I would say
uh coach and I had this wonderful
expression and he Victor course done he
would say uh weaknesses are only
weaknesses if you can attack exactly and
if the pawn on C4 cannot be attacked
it's not a weakness
um there's a problem like you should put
like you should understand should I put
the King on D3 or F2 that's a question
right Aram needs to answer and then also
oh how did you end up in this position
decided to exchange the world I'm not
sure about this exchange even though
King E6 I think and they just make it to
the time control by the way King E6 that
is a funny move because he is offering a
check in this Pawn Yeah he is offering
the B6 Pawn as well but yes sir you need
to know not not that he made a move in
two seconds basically on his call yes I
see it now he has 30. so he went all the
way down to two seconds and made a move
basically he didn't have a have enough
time to calculate all the lines I was
about to say uh time travel addicts uh
do that Nicholas and Mishra I love the
we're talking about the two nights uh in
the previous game I love the two minor
pieces in this position it feels to me
like uh it's not the best combination
too right
well yeah for example two nights at the
depends on the position two Bishops on
almost always great and then bishop and
knights usually it's the worst like
combination of the two like pieces yeah
here again it's just that this Knight is
wonderfully secured but
not the ideal Square the ideal Square
would be something like
six and that's what the process is
trying
to just moved his Bishop in order to
vacate the F6 Square I think he's
aspiring for Knight G8 F6 I see this as
black desperately trying to hold and I
would be surprised if white doesn't win
and then knowing how tricky he is until
you grab his Pawn on H7 this Knight on
F6 he'll he will create something are we
jumping in the pool or is it the ice
bucket challenge
who wins uh I like white very much and
let's just check out the other uh
competition as we've had two uh decisive
games uh Andrew hung by the way came
over and uh and it was a great interview
you I could see you were enjoying it
yeah sir great beautiful chest
a a really really nice game let's just
jump in Justin looks awful this last
position these two Palms down in a rook
ending what is there to
discussed start for Justin and he never
recovered no after that I feel bad for
him because he's such a talented player
he is and then he showed during the
during the Juniors how talented he is
and absolutely he's such a uh like you
know inspiring and he plays interesting
chess for sure and it's hard to see him
struggling exactly well in this case uh
samyan who's doing very very well in the
tournament by the way for his time for a
second and after this win he's gonna
catch up with the leader of the
tournament quick question I mean am I
blundering you know normally speaking
whenever I can get into a kingpod and
game a pawn up that's usually good
enough usually you're not wondering yes
but I I am I like yeah exactly am I not
uh I mean there's no way you're not on
like it's two pounds exactly so
I don't you find this move a little
confusing I mean
I mean I Love Gaining Tempe yeah when I
was talking to you back off my mind I
was also thinking of requesting why not
Rook V6 all right
in any case it's just he probably
decided Rook B7 I don't have to
calculate anything and it's listening uh
but forever and okay this was the
Pillsbury let's just see how they got
here
he did play Queen C2 by the way we were
looking at uh yeah these kinds of
tactical ideas and I liked my White's
position I mean perspective of the
attack
me too oh but check it out I mean that
was fine
sure about this one this one but okay
three pounds for the exchange okay but
these pieces are very badly yeah
absolutely oh I don't like Queen B3 I'm
not sure I like Queen can we do
something quickly like can we oh
Queen D4 is coming I'm I want time to
consolidate all of my pieces as well
that's why yeah uh can you put King on
can we ask our opponent would you mind
if I play King H1 and then look at it
right okay uh I take a different
approach uh to the position so my
Approach would be what's my most
powerful piece that's obvious my queen
a queen is my most powerful I don't
think so sir but my queen what's your
queen is
correct what is my queen doing on A4
absolutely nothing what would be a good
Square for my queen if you could pick a
square
I'd go to D6
immediately now yeah I make the illegal
move Queen D6 so I was thinking five
queen queen A5 perfect five perfect
Queen A5 go to E5 Queen D1 go to D6 but
whatever you do you go somewhere
like uh for me by the way my mom's
problem was Queen five okay I'm a pond
Grabber I you never mind never mind just
give me a pawn just give me a point
you're perfect and your like back rack
is not
explain your Pawn
9c6
okay so Queen D6 doesn't win it once
because there is Queen C1
that's the whole idea okay okay Queen E1
but what did Queen D1 do it gave I won a
pawn I mean and I'm bringing myself it's
very important right I want a part and I
coordinate my pieces so for me the queen
on A4 is out of the game you didn't like
Queen B3 I didn't like Queen B3 your
approach might have been Queenie coming
across but yours is uh looking good
either one Queen B3 let's take a look
how did it go where whoa okay maybe that
was a surprise move for uh
for white here because he did win the
pawn maybe he thought this position for
him is it possible that he died like
that it's possible uh no this this
position could never be winning uh three
and two is always holding always holding
with the bishop especially after Bishop
like E6 how are you winning my pawns
exactly I put B3 King F6 well no I have
to win a pawn I I otherwise it might be
worse if I if you put your King on F6
and your pawn and B3 I might be worse as
white maybe not losing but I might not
be so you're gonna so I have to yes I
have to chase you if you go here I will
go here
and if you go to D7 excuse me Bishop to
D7 I'm going to keep chasing you
until I well actually that might just be
a drawing spot
that is true yeah and also we have a
result uh
officially wanted his game against
Justin that was The Rook ending we
thought it was hopeless when we came
into it after Rook H7 Rook A6 Rook H7
it's collapsing immediately and you
cannot even check on A5
because that is a king
is on the a file see that's the funny
thing about Chelsea you make a moment of
saying oh I don't want to calculate but
next move still you gotta come on you
got to calculate okay that's uh that was
very very nice uh for it so we have
three games you're Mining and two games
on the
video section and then
games
yes one game a a piece not two games in
the a section and a game on on this
video section and and then Nicholas uh
versus Mishra game by the way uh it's
funny that we were we were saying that I
would love to reposition the night
Knight to G8 and it's funny that the two
thesis would be yeah both uh vulnerable
uh to uh and I'm telling you this
players are very tricky Nico's is known
as a very tricky player that's right it
won't be easy for abimania to win the
game but maybe he will come up with
something hold on I I'm thinking
Nicholas is white as the one who's
trying to win the game you're thinking
Abby
you said you're picking up is winning
that's not so confused no I'm thinking
the two minor pieces win oh
yeah sir now we're on the scene yeah
sorry I'm thinking yeah I'm thinking
white with the two minor faces win so
and uh all we need to do so I'll be mind
you it needs to be tricky the funny
thing is that if I for example play
Knight G4 right now
and that's an easy draw yes exactly we
have another interview am I going no yes
sir
we should want to uh talk to you make
them but we have some young and he will
join us as we take a look at uh this
game of uh
for just a moment this was the two
nights versus the rook and I thought
darush was going to win I'm no longer
sure because he's gave up his age Pawn
in the meanwhile uh semian will join us
as he has won his game
uh let me see with Justin
hi welcome again nice to see you uh tell
us what happened today take it away
crazy crazy game yeah I went for this
opening that please yeah you can either
so that or the cursor
petraf is kind of an opening where you
know it's kind of it's always difficult
to come up with something that wins on
the spot of course so I went for this
line that's not that popular but you
know it has been played many times I'll
show it in a second so D4
94. if you don't mind I just share a
story with you
so
what you were saying about the Petrov
painting an opponent finding a a line
that wins on the spot ha how about
finding a line that gives an advantage
so as a young boy
and there was a major tournament going
up in Vancouver BC uh Vancouver British
Columbia and I was I was from Seattle
Paul Karas
was playing in the great tournament up
in the Vancouver but I couldn't play I
was going to school as a Schoolboy
and he was playing one of the strong
British Columbian Masters and he has
white Paul cares got this position and
very quickly like it was all part of the
winning plan
he played d2d3 oh and then after night
C6 Bishop E2 D5 Knight D2 it was a
reverse fellador that he won easily like
23 months
it was like I was so ready for somebody
to show me how to get an advantage
against the metro and it was d2d3 by
caress you came up with this line and
yeah sorry take it away sure I mean D3
here as you said is I'm sure some
players will do that maybe reports
you're very Richie exactly exactly but
you really have to have a certain
mindset exactly exactly I don't
understand how plain white you can play
d2d3 on move three I don't know exactly
okay and get in the patch yeah and D4
and yeah this was an old line D5 Knight
takes Knight D7 they used to take on D7
in the old days yeah I think they still
do there are many many moves right that
are played it's really one of the key
positions we can remember Magnus play in
Napa in the world championship exactly
um in this line
I castled I guess the most
famous game here is uh Fabi versus uh
you in 2021 I think in Titus steel right
um takes takes 95 Bishop E3 we actually
went exactly like you know like they did
okay I'm not sure if my opponent knew
that I would think he did because he
played pretty quickly and it's not the
most
obviously I would say right he played C6
F4
takes takes G6
Knight C3 this is kind of the key
position there are many many moves here
and B6 SC played is what you played
against Fabi right
so it's funny you keep saying you and
it's no it's not me I didn't
implement
yes exactly yes please exactly
um
Rook D1 Bishop F5 Queen D2 Queen D7 you
know I was already playing out of prep I
didn't really
you know it's hard to get an advantage
on the spot in Petro so I just wanted to
play something just some interesting
position that's not balanced okay but
and you haven't achieved that that's
true but as I started thinking about
about the position
I thought that I could get worse very
easily if I don't make the Right Moves
so if you if you imagine that
well like Bishop goes to what I say E7
C5 black castles and ghost D4
resign exactly exactly so that was
worrying
an example of what could go wrong
exactly yes I guess as always in the
openings you just look at the most
forced lines and then like all right so
he knows the moves it will be a draw but
here looking at the position I thought
it doesn't have to be a drop if I don't
play well I might lose okay
so I played 92 the idea is to play
Knight G3
attack division like the bishop
Bishop E6 but a mysterious move
confusing one yes yeah I mean if you go
if he goes Bishop E7 and castles and you
go Knight three G3 and take the bishop
oh okay you executed a trade exactly
right uh Bishop esek's confused okay B4
it wasn't it was just like a move to
I guess to save time even though I spent
quite a lot of time on B4 I was just
thinking okay I'll play before he will
think
and then while he's thinking I'll come
come up with something better
but the funny thing was he played every
move instantly no so as a result I just
had to think a lot on every move
that's funny so he instantly replied to
Bishop before with Bishop E7 exactly
expected your move B4 exactly which is a
kind of a confusing move but it didn't
find it
unperturbed okay so
Knight G3
1985 F5
so it was kind of a bluff I wasn't
really sure if I could do that but I
just understood that if I don't play F5
and let's say I let him do a couple of
moves say H4 and then Rook C8 C5 then
again it's just terrible exactly so I
knew I had to go F5
takes Bishop G5
again I was thinking okay he has to play
H4 right 90. after H4 have many options
we will yeah yeah come back to you in a
second so I thought okay I'll play
Bishop G5 and I will think while he's
thinking on which move to make
and three places
will you stop
I think okay and what was your plan
zero plan I thought he would think and
then I'll come up with a plan he played
instantly so I realized that I have to
do something right there are three moves
that I was thinking about Bishop E7 92
and 95. and Knight F5 too of course
the positions I think are very complex
I'm not sure which which movie is best
I took an F5 I guess we won't go into
details but okay you went back your Pawn
let's go yeah
Bishop takes a new thought the resulting
position should favor you I wasn't sure
actually when I just started looking at
it I thought that after Bishop E4 which
is what you did maybe just for some of
our viewers that yes black recaptures
for the king queen G5 check
yes you must be better in that case
so Bishop E4 and it's a weird position
because I think
both of our kings are quite shaky
and at the same time it's not clear how
to attack each one of them right
so Bishop F6 Rook GA for example Bishop
F6 Rook G8 Rook D2 and F2 Queen so the
light squares yes G4 it looks like four
E6 and I was just thinking he would do
that play King D7 and I wasn't sure what
to do targeting E2 targeting pardon me
G2 right so instead of Bishop F6 I
thought I would play Bishop G5 the idea
being
he cannot play Slowly with say 26
because Rook F6 will always be dangerous
right at the same time if I manage to
somehow push this bishop back
then his King is stuck in the center and
I will open it with E6 right
which is kind of what happened so you
play Queen G4 right H3
Queen H5 an interesting move I'm not
sure why you didn't play Queen G3 right
I think I would have done the same thing
that we will see in a second but again
I'm not sure um I was low on time so I
was kind of just making moves and you
know
um it's a double-edged position a
dangerous position to be in time trouble
yeah absolutely so when I first went for
it I thought I must be slightly worse
but probably okay okay but then the more
I looked at it the more I realized that
he doesn't have a good response after d
to E1 in
I guess wherever his Queen moves
this idea of taking on e4 is very very
dangerous right
so
maybe again for for our viewers you
cannot really recreate because then
e-cig just ends the game right he really
has to play very quickly with his King
in a sensor okay
and yet that's very hard to do king D7
Rook takes E4 that's cool exactly okay
so Rook G8 okay my idea was Rook takes
E4 and here
again well he took on G5 which made my
life a lot easier because you know at
least for the cool material it's easy to
play yeah it's time travel
GE was the move that you spent all your
time on exactly
so
my thought process was to go Queen D6
threatening made but then after Queen G5
I don't think I have I have more than a
perpetual
frequency 167.
7 I think he's six
Rook F6 check and his King just goes for
a walk exactly oh my goodness oh no he's
running all the way down to B2 exactly
that's funny the good thing is I can you
always have a big situation yeah right
so then I thought
oh wait wait I can go E6 include E6
exactly it takes like a queen D6 and now
we're back in business and now
whichever piece he takes on G5 with
let's say a queen I think I take on E6
and not on C6 and then I win
so for example King d8 Rook D1 right
and unlike in the previous line and I I
now can activate my Rook yes
seven I guess maybe for our viewers
right
so the problem is while he was thinking
on
in this position I realized that after d
takes E4 E6 he has Rook takes G5 and so
I have had to pretty much hope that I
could could find something
because otherwise I mean it's just draw
it most I don't think there is anything
here
wow so Queen D7 check King f8
no Rook takes no no E7 check King G7
yeah and he walks away so I panicked
I like it I've had it and but luckily I
think Bishop F6 wins I think
I mean it's just
[Music]
improvisation at the board exactly wow I
think
the only defense from Queen D6 is Queen
G6 to uh but then I think I think Rook
D1 and now you're threatening and then
queen of 5.8
so I was happy with that right
um
I mean he probably saw that so he played
Rook G5 pretty quickly but then after
Rook F4 I think it's quite hopeless
because his King is so bad I mean if he
castles long then with all of these
queen queen E6 and stuff it's really
really bad exactly look if I've
Queen C3
yeah threatening CC C6 Rook E6
and F7 there's a check on it as well the
only I guess the only thing I had to
worry about was going to xf7 but then
Queen take Queen h8 wins yeah and that's
it yeah
he castled
I just took 27 I mean maybe there are
some other moves that win but
I thought 2K7 can't be bad
thank you for that by the way as a pawn
Grabber it can't be bad yeah 25 and by
the way Queen G7 was also Potential
Threat yeah F7 a326 I think so many
threats and after Queen E5 I think I
could win on the spot but I actually you
know I saved myself a couple of hours I
took on E5 but then
after I took on E5 I saw that he became
kind of happy so I thought what am I
missing and I think I'm missing Rook F7
I think this could be a quicker way to
win so after Queen C3 it's Queen C3 it's
made yes
ah and uh after King B8
I think rookie eight wins and now you
have Queen A3 inmate exactly you could
have saved us a lot of time yes you know
think about the commentators
I mean it's not all about you
nice that's a pretty move right yeah
setting up a mate uh sorry we have to
call the action because we've got other
games that are going on you went on to
win a very nice Rook ending and uh very
very important win nice and I thank you
for sharing that whole thing with E6 and
which sequence I like the improvisation
thank you very much and good luck
Championship rounds coming up
as we have just a few games remaining
um Aram and the two oh no he did yeah
this is that uh drawn Rook uh ending uh
two pardon me
there was this a lovely story of Gary
Kasparov he's playing in what was called
the spartacion of the Soviet Union and
he had a bishop and a pawn versus a rook
he had a bishop and pawn versus a rook
and the game was adjourned
and get hi big and welcome back and Gary
Kasparov called up his trainer Michael
bobinick he said I'm adjourned I have a
bishop and pawn I'm worse against rook
in an ending
and he didn't tell about the Nick the
position he didn't he says I have a
bishop on Paul and his compensation for
an exchange in the ending and Bob
thenick said is the bishop anchored
is it protected in this case the bishop
is anchored yeah
uh and Gary said no
I've been exced you're lost
and he didn't know the position and he
was right
that was it that was the end of the
story uh in this position it became as a
draw why
The Bishop's think
[Music]
ing patterns no because I'll always like
I always can run it well like worst case
I always can run honestly
exactly G8 or G8 and it looks nice and I
always have a Tempo uh so there's no uh
but I just thought that was a very nice
story
yeah I mean Gary loves that story by the
way he tells it a a lot uh let's just
take a look at some standings as well if
we have them and we do
a standings take it away Benjamin book
is still leading the tournament with
John Burke who won a great game yes
thank you it was a four and a half
points and Benjamin had a quick draw
today and tie for a third it's ramnag
and Nikos theater exactly now Nicholas
he could still yeah he's still playing
and therefore uh jump in and you know if
something probably Nicholas either is
gonna make a draw or win the game well
let's just see uh what is going on in
that game
uh this was the game with the two minor
pieces versus The Rook I thought that
white could be winning this game or even
put it another way I think that white
should be winning this game I really
don't think white is winning this game
though why Bishop H6 how how would you
play just uh clear the cobwebs uh for a
sec can I play Roxy too that's the
question sure okay that very directly
tax money
and let's say I want to uh win the pawn
how exactly am I supposed to win the
ball and Rook C3 Chuck Rook C3 check
I don't know my king isn't uh
my pieces with the king I need my king
on F4 yeah I want to win the party
that's why I'm trying to put my king on
F5 I mean the thing is that as long as I
can exchange F2 Pawn on to E4 Pawn I'm
not risking anything that then it's a
simple draw
I really thought around here white
should
be winning
um but I have a feeling Nicholas is
gonna make a draw and everybody is
holding the position that's how I think
Nicholas is going to join the leaders
okay and time for force with Benjamin
and John wonderful uh the position
between Aram and darush in my opinion
has changed completely I don't know what
happened but I don't know it's looking
great no I think white might be winning
suddenly the position why do I think
white might be winning well first of all
there was a huge loss if there was a
black H Pawn on the board
White's night would have to be there you
know keeping that pawn under a watchful
eye he won that pawn so now everything
just went to the queen side and I'm
looking at the position and whites
nights have anchored squares but I have
a feeling it will end and
what do you want to drive what okay why
how are you winning my king king
D6 okay and then King C6 okay and then
I'll just put six put the pawn on B6 now
and I I have questions can I play like
no probably I will improve my rook and
then play B5 exchange and then probably
we'll take on C5 I'll take on A2 and
make a troll
do you know you lost the whole audience
with what you just said
you went really really really really
fast uh what did you say you you wanted
to go B5 and Rook takes to activate to
Rook first how do you do that probably
Rook h8 Rook h a but it's your move
that's the problem that's what I'm just
selling you my ideas following ideas out
there okay uh yeah just a second we just
went really really fast Knight A4 King
went back to D6 and
how do I how do I coordinate so I mess
you up
um where is my night I went to G3 and E4
which looks good like if you go to bd5
the problem is that I can play B5 better
and exchange the
yeah um let's say Knight F4
night here
and King C7 is holding
it looks okay
um I like white uh we'll see if this has
been a complete turnaround or not
because earlier I really did like
darusha's position I was really very
dangerous for a white it was like for
sure as we get prepared
to close our broadcast once again we
want to say to our audience thank you so
much for joining us I hope you like our
coverage of these Classics uh these have
been very very nice for us the summer of
Chess and St Louis continues by the way
because we have uh Fisher random chest
nine LX coming up yeah it's a great
event and we will start the event with
ultimate moves and then it will switch
to Rapid which is going to be 20 plus
five and we will have the best players
of the world they will they will indeed
and of course we have ultimate moves in
conjunction with the chess 9lx the
ultimate moves is a kind of uh well
trash talking tournament
I do I do I mean come prepare for the
insults yeah come prepared to me
insulting receive
and that too
so that's very nice and once again we're
going to just take a quick Gander at the
standings as we close our show take a
look at the B group and one game
remaining absolutely we still have
basuring and Armand uh play a game yep
but most probably it will end in a draw
but before for now we have time for
first three ways which is
Hong and Chandra with five points and
Armand and Brandon they're tying for
fourth and third basically right and
it's just so close with like uh
armaan is gonna be behind only half a
point exactly uh two great wins by
samyon and Andrew a big shout out to
them for coming and sharing and once
again thank you so very very much for
joining us uh we're here every day 4 P.M
Central Time guys that's the one that's
the one and in the meanwhile
good night and we'll see you all
tomorrow have a have a lovely rest of
your day yeah absolutely you two bacon
bye
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited